[Music]  trade works in  dry land african countries where people  are living on just on the front line of  the climate crisis areas  [Music]  i can tell you about the reserve because  of the climate change  he has lost some of the fertility of his  land  the rain is not no more reliable so some  of the crops he has been growing  as now not able to be grown and then  able to harvest good things  [Music]  the changing climates made his farming  no more enough to produce for his family  to feed the whole year  poor people living in there if they lose  their  security of producing and living in that  area  then after 20 years that  place will not be able to support  the peoples living around  there were some rivers which have been  flowing  year round we need to have some  support to cross those rivers because  they have water flowing during even dry  season  but nowadays because of this climate  christ those rivers and streams which  are no more there